In the last lesson, you saw how
Xcode can automatically create
a view controller and
wire it up for you.
You even added a code to
this view controller.
At this point you might be wondering
what is a view controller and
how do I know what methods
to override in it?
As we're going to see,
the documentation will be our guide.
The view controller is a special kind of
class that, as the name implies,
controls a view and handles all of
the actions required by that view.
In iOS development,
this means that this class is usually
a subclass of UIViewController.
Inherited from the UIkit framework.
The view controller is called by a OS
when certain events happen to it or
your app overall.
In the beginning, your app is not
running as soon as the icon is pressed
in moves through the inactive state and
immediately into the active state.
When an event happens,
maybe a phone call or
the user decides to go to another app,
your app will transition to the inactive
state and then to the background.
>From the background state,
after a few seconds it will
go to the suspended state.
What happens when the user
wants to go back to your app?
If your app is in the background,
it will go through the inactive
state to being active.
Last but not least,
if iOS needs more memory and
your app is in suspended state and
may be moved off memory entirely,
and we're back to the beginning of
this diagram to the not running state.
How do I know or functions UIV
controllers has that I should override?
How do I know which
functions get called and
then the what events
in this state diagram?
It's all in the documentation and it's
always the first place you should look.
Now, it's a good time to learn how
to open up documentation in Xcode.
Let's open up the ViewController.swift
file, and navigate to the top.
Here, you can see the line this
shows that the ViewController
class inherits from UIViewController.
If you hold down the option key,
you can see that the cursor changes to
a question mark when we go over a class.
In this example, UIViewController.
If we click once,
we can see a contextual manual come up
showing us all the information
about the UIViewController class.
Clicking anywhere else
dismisses this contextual menu.
If you click anywhere you can
dismiss the documentation pop up.
Another way to see the full
documentation is to hold down the option
key but this time double click
on the UIViewController class.
This will show you the documentation
window and open it in full screen.
Showing us UIViewController.
Another way to view the documentation
window is to go under help and
choose documentation and API reference.
You can also get this window to come up
by using the key combination Shift+Cmd+0
anywhere within Xcode.
Take a moment now to look for
viewDidLoad under the UI view
controller documentation.